bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono un po di j
oggi domenica andiamo avanti con è più
il ragazzo mi sta inceppando all'inizio
del video sabato che era ieri mi ero
dimenticato ripartire facendo la
premessa ma me l'avete fatto notare
ovviamente tutti ma non è che me lo sono
dimenticato e che non lo faccio più è
semplicemente che non so che cosa avevo
bevuto tipo bocca o cose del genere ma
nel momento in cui editava non so perché
ho tagliato la parte iniziale non mi
chiedete perché non lo so pensate come
scommesso vabbè
partiamo come primo livello raga direi
di iniziare con fatality non so che
cos'è finish him o cazzo questo l'avevo
già fatto ma che cazzo ok perfetto raga
siamo partiti benissimo direi di
cambiare questo lavoro comunque già
l'avevo fatto uno simile
vabbè andiamo con un boltro subito
partiamo subito con eddy cazzo che colpo
di testa ma neanche ronaldo ho vinto
ok il volto più lungo di sempre raga
incredibile
voglio provare a farlo perché mi sembra
un po strano che io abbia vinto subito è
ok
oggi sono così raga pazienza vinco tutto
facciamo oggi mi sento carico mi sento
carico a bestia facciamo facciamo tutti
i livelli possibili perché tanto di
vinco tutti botto run che non riesco mai
oggi ci riesco come tutti molto ranco uk
e suo padre vai perfetto madonna ma da
una donna
dico tutto by you ok
ovviamente il fatto di vincere tutto ma
è anche solo per le gambe quindi ho
vinto con le gambe sono tre vittorie
perché quella racconto come la vittoria
al team edward trovo andiamo anche con
il world troppo direi ripartire anche
con questo c'e liuc che si dà al canto
così eh va beh partito anche gli ufo dio
10 spade insieme tutte nella direzione
sbagliata sono un mito
ok allora proviamo perché se non ciak
con un colletto in testa è perché dice
una valigetta da lavoro perfetto come
faccia beckham e due con una spada
no non ci credo
che culo oggi veramente ho fiducia in me
stesso andiamo con the survival sono com
perché mi si è sposata la pagina ok
scusate speria prima era così non me ne
sono accorto vabbè c'è se steve che ha
tentato di no a steve scusatemi eddie
che ha tentato di uccidermi ma non mi ha
preso e poi c'è un mio clone che mi ha
infilzato con nostro braccio e la sua
testa sta facendo delle cose oscene
vabbè uk non guardare ok è luke
oddio ti ha infilzato proprio lì ma
cazzo che cosa macabra ok perfetto
madonna che schivata maledetto ed addio
ok ci sono di nuovo la gara ci sono di
un maledetto nonno ciak
ok sono vivo sono jack incastrato nella
ruota posteriore ma edizione no no non
ci credo ma dai ma come si fa ma perché
mi rimane sempre una testa sul bene
qualsiasi cosa io faccia
vabbè raga caviamo livello andiamo sui
top 5 battaglie dei boss non mi chiedete
che cos'è se non lo ciak che diciamo non
sta bene e stavo meglio prima anch'io
senza di lui maledetto ok devo riuscire
a roma che cazzo come faccio a darlo
tipo aspetta bravo fai vedere che una
gamba nello stomaco non si scalfisce ok
perché ma cazzo
neanche le asse mi scalfiscono oggi io
sono highlander neanche steve che si
attacca la mia testa neanche un tronco
d'albero sono immortale
macchina se va beh fate passare un treno
già che ci siete un aereo fatemelo
cadere addosso
che cazzo sono ancora vivo a cosa c'e
raga io la gamma di un vecchio un'ascia
un'altra cha e steve tutti quanti
conficcati nello stomaco è impossibile
e vabbè per lo più sono anche senza
gambe ma sto andando avanti lo stesso
comunque vabbè lasciamo perdere
proviamo a cambiare livello perché
questo mi sembra impossibile
e allora andiamo si impossible raga
riprova fare come l'altra volta anche se
non ci riuscirò mai più a nerano era una
roba tipo madonna madonna ci stavo
riuscendo ci stavo riuscendo di nuovo ma
vabbè impossibile madonna madonna no
piano piano si no perché
ma perché l'avevo schivati tutti ma che
cazzo è impossibile ragazzi livelli sono
impossibili sono fai qualcosa tipo ma è
ovvio che no no no è successo ma come ho
fatto a morire lì o schivati tutti ma
non ci credo come sono morto cioè mi ha
infilzato qualcosa ma cosa c'è lì o
schivati tutti e tre
ma fa ancora ok steve questo era un
allenamento per il prossimo episodio
stai tranquillo non ti buttare giù
ce la faremo nel prossimo andiamo con
eddy devo provare a lanciare no perfetto
come non detto ho sbagliato
va beh forse ci riesco lo stesso vai vai
no no c'ero quasi c'ero quasi
maledizione dai ce la posso fare non è
impossibile tuffo bamba bike madonna che
tuffo manco alle olimpiadi fanno sito
maledizione ok perfetto come non detto
vi si sono staccate le gambe c'è ma
porca [ __ ] allora aspettate un secondo
ci riprova l'ultima volta se non ci
riesco [ __ ] no kat
ma l'ultima mano ci paragona guardate
bene ma ne avrò passato un milione
all'ultima sono ma non ci posso credere
cioè raga sono diventato una pignatta di
nuovo devo riuscire
cos'è questo boltro l'abbiamo fatto ma
si dai facciamo non altro perché quello
era abbastanza corto ce l'abbiamo finito
subito di nuovo con eddy troviamo di
nuovo tribute perfetto
ok oggi è di impedito non riusciamo a
tenere le palle in mano non pensate a
doppi sensi
ok fourballs
ok non riesco ma dopo il caso faccia
vince a win di perfetto ma non riesco a
non c'è perfetta madonna
no no ma cosa preso cos'era quella roba
lì porca [ __ ] devo riuscire se al primo
due secondi di ball troppo vinto
perfetto proviamo con sciacallo raisi
hard c'è ma tu veramente pensi che io
faccia quella easy cioè stai parlando
con fa vj e vuoi che faccia la easy ma
mi si è staccata naga addio rimbalzo
cazzo a da quando c'è che rimbalza cessa
cosa mi è nuova va beh noi proviamo a
toglierci se vai ma piano piano si
grande grande ciak baggio ma che cazzo
oggi non ci riesco va beh è quella hard
è più facile comunque
e vai piano piano si decolla
ok ma se si si by ciak vice cech weiss
ha vinto anche con jacques fanno
motocross e questa mi sembra strana
perché come faccia guidare una moto
cross
spero sia steve perfetto come non detto
vai andiamo steve facciamo vedere chi
siamo
come faccio ad andare avanti up perfetto
ma che figo che cosa epica e la figata
assurda suo livello raga by cos'è vice
steve vai vai a vedere che freestyle a
ma che cazzo come hai fatto a morire
così
raga serve la musica adatta per questo
perché veramente etico ma è perfetto
by step bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye steve vai così grande
grandissimo steve grandi fermi un attimo
notate quanto e sexy steve quando vai
motocross è fantastico c'è guidare così
è veramente epico va beh ripartiamo vai
standby
se vai così vai così steve cose oggi
abbiamo vinto
vabbè era una cosa un po strana questa
ma non importa
andiamo su one man army cosa vuol dire o
a menarmi dell'off cos'è devo sorpassare
tutti quanti si è perfetto non lascia
che il primo è di esse ma così questo è
troppo facile chelsea ma vi posso
scrivere tutti anche steve stesso ok
come non detto singh stesso è l'unico
che riesce a mettermi no no
maledetto fratello mio lasciami ci siamo
separati alla nascita
vabbè andiamo con 2 steve a sto punto
tanto non fa niente ok perfetto non
sarai mica pubblica farmi fuori no babbo
natale
[ __ ] no no kat l'ho fatta morire
ma che stupido sono è perfetto di nuovo
si stima è l'unico che riesce a mettermi
in difficoltà diciamo madonna mia che
muscoli che muscoli nel deretano che
c'hai nel campo anzi si perfetto mai
così no devo riuscire
devo riuscire a vincerla ma dice no ma
perché raga voglio soltanto fare una
cosa per per vedere se riesco ad
ammazzare qualcuno lo infilzato col poco
oh mio dio mi sta venendo a prendere
oddio no nonno ciak attento no ma perché
ok raga mission impossible spero che sia
con si va anzi è da scegliere quindi
scelgo steve vai she's so che ce la puoi
fare mai no
è una roba un po deciso no sì dai
no ce l'aveva fatta da edizione devo
riuscire tipo a staccarmi quando parto
perché così by steven jimi orgoglioso
sui prendimi orgoglioso stipendi cazzo è
difficilissimo c'è
no è impossibile che scarso c'è ragazza
è una cosa no il pogo mie parti col poco
maledizione
madonna a madonna una donna
oddio ma che vittorio ho fatto no questo
è la replay questo è assolutamente da
replay
oddio cioè la cosa più assurda di sempre
madonna questo è quasi peggio di quello
l'altra volta raga
vabbè steve ti sei ripreso per prima lo
sapevo che quella era soltanto un
allenamento
io ho sempre creduto in te se il
migliore te lo dirò sempre sei il
migliore quindi raga direi che per oggi
posso chiudere qui se il video vi è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato un
commento vi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come non i video trovate
nella descrizione se non siete ancora
iscritti iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo in
un prossimo video bella ragazze